they say one little leak can sink a
massive ship
massive ship can completely sink because
of one little news by the way your
business your enterprise you as an
entrepreneur you can absolutely sink
your ship if you don't plug the little
leaks you have in your business and
today I'm going to talk to you about
three different companies from three
different industries if I'm running them
how I'm going to find those leak and how
I would plug them I wish we had hours
and hours together to go through your
business but whatever I'm talking about
here today I'm gonna give you feedback
on what you need to do at the end with
your business so the first thing I do is
whenever I'm running any businesses and
we have an area that's not going well
like today we just had a conference car
with a pretty strong conference call to
have with everybody and we went through
areas that we need to be improving in
first thing I do is I write out all the
steps and I do this with every aspect of
my life of my business for instance if
it's health I write out every single
thing I do with my diet and every single
routine I have would working out and
every single routine I have would sleep
everything okay so step number one is
take out your business and write all the
steps it could be 20 steps it could be
ten steps customer comes in what they do
next and what they do that until they
buy from you all the steps once you
write all the steps prioritize the five
most important steps so go this the most
important step than this then this and
this then rank how well you do in each
step then bring a group of two three
four five people that work with you that
are also leaders who can say I think we
can do this to improve this I think we
can do this to improve this we're not
doing this that well then put an action
plan together and attack the action plan
so whatever I just told you right now
watch how I do this with these different
businesses I got a sales office any
sales office real estate insurance it
doesn't matter what it is sales office
we got a restaurant here and then we
have construction business here let's
start off here with sales office I'm
running a sales office real estate
pharmaceutical sales whatever it is I
want to find out what my leaks in my
business are so I either have inbound
calls or customers coming in
I have outbound calls reaching out I'm
reaching out or I'm getting a call
I'm getting an email of interest I'm
getting a you know message I'm getting
your visit to my restaurant or to my
business whatever it is well I found so
if I'm in bounds cause somebody calls me
yes I would like to talk to real estate
agent about buying a house
hypothetically what is my script I test
the script
what is the questions asked what
questions are we asking the sales rep is
asking the customer that's called in 3
what are my FAQ do I have an FAQ sheet
so for instance if you're running real
estate there are 20 questions that
everybody's going to ask everybody that
buys the house asks the same exact
questions
everybody that's selling and buying
asked the same exact question so I need
an FAQ sheet do I have an FAQ sheet next
thing it's called call to action so
let's get a person calls I have a script
then I ask questions they ask me
questions I already know the FAQ then
it's call-to-action meaning when do you
want to buy the house how soon do you
want to buy the house all you already
pre-qual you already have a property
your norwood area i'm ask you call to
action what do we do next then we're
going to go there's all time to go do
whatever we're doing and then we're
going to close and when I close then
it's follow-up once I got too close then
I follow up as we got closed and there's
onboarding paperwork all this stuff
filling out all these things I got to do
then its referral then it's nurturing
that relationship if it's outbound and
I'm reaching out to the customer let's
just say I am a social media marketing
company and I'm running an agency and
I'm out sounding I'm trying to reach out
to people first I got to find identify
who my ideal client is do I even know my
ideal client is to call then it's volume
of contacts meaning if I'm selling a
membership to a magazine its volume if
I'm selling a subscription to a certain
membership or whatever it's volume I'm
selling your gym membership it's a
volume I'm calling everybody but if I'm
selling exotic cars Lamborghinis
Ferraris
I'm not contacting 200 people in the day
I'm nurturing meaning I'm going to
country club events I'm going to certain
speaking events I'm going to certain
places that people of my
are going to be around so volume is
quantity versus quality depending on the
product that you sell you need to be
clear about that then am I good at
finding customers some companies are
finding problems they don't know how to
find the right customers then what's my
script when I'm out bound close and do I
close well I'd have a finding or closing
prompt follow-up onboarding referral
notes or all the things so now once I
know what my inbound and my outbound is
and I write this out let's just say this
is you I'm going to circle the most
important ones on inbound for instance
FAQ
that's important for everybody know the
FAQ is great that's important questions
asked as important close as important
and then follows got to be up there then
I'm going to score every one of them how
well we do our script socks men worth -
we don't even have a script honestly -
questions asked we don't even know what
questions to ask three fa Q's we do have
somewhat of an FAQ 6 I'm scoring all of
them then whatever those four were that
were important to me and whatever the
ones that are the lowest ranking I'm
figuring out how to improve those and
then I improve them it's that simple I'm
doing the same thing here and I'm
improving it then I get a couple ideas
then we improve again let me do another
example for you here's a restaurant I'm
running a restaurant I have a lot of
friends that come to me for advice about
restaurants and they run businesses
restaurants from doing a half a million
a year to restaurants from fifteen
million dollars per year and they're
always asking how would you improve the
tab would you improve that project and
for me I've been to thousands of
restaurants around the world and I love
good food and I'm so meticulous that I
pay attention to every single thing
about restaurants because if I ever ran
one I would want them to be ran a
certain way this is what I'd be paying
attention to from you your location of
your restaurant you're saying I'm not
doing that well is it even a good
location I went to a restaurant the
other day yesterday in Houston Pollan
we're looking at the sushi spot the
sushi spot was all the way in the back I
couldn't find this place food was great
everything was good horrible location if
this is the Main Street
these were the businesses up front the
sushi spot was here there is no Street
there
that's a horrible horrible location for
trite the location where can I be found
online Yelp on after my every word
parking is part
next entrance presentation I'm scoring
every one of these from zero to ten I am
truly scoring every one of those zero to
ten next my process hosted what's the
script when somebody comes who do I hire
what is the attire what is she wearing
what does he want what's their look
what's their attitude do I want somebody
attractive what age do I want how
helpful do I want them to be how do I
track how helpful they are I'm scoring
this with all my hostesses if I got five
hostesses I'm scoring every one of them
and I'm firing the bottom two okay if
they're not adults I'm ending I'm hiring
somebody who shot them let me explain
what I mean by shopping them when I
worked at valleys and I was selling
memberships at Bally's I used to shop
all the other Bally's everybody would
take this valleys and Chicago is the
best one this Daly's in New York is the
best one I don't work in that valley I
would call that Valley I would call that
valleys until the best guy at that
valleys picked up and I would act like
I'm a customer wanted to buy membership
and see how he handled it like wow no
wonder this guy's number two in the
company no wonder this guy's number
three in the company no wonder this
guy's number one the company he is the
Beast and closing on an appointment I
didn't even know what to say he closed
to me and I work at Bally's I'm shopping
all my hostesses I'm bringing ten people
and I'm having all the shop of different
personalities single mother single
female a husband and wife kids
I want a whole experience how she
handles kids being rattled and loud
I want to shop my hostess is next I'm
beyond what's the music is it too loud
what kind of music in my plane is that a
hip-hop music is that a lounge with jazz
is it more salsa is it more like current
music that we have is it just you know
the white noise music is a shot day what
am i playing what station of my plane
here how loud is it how's the lining
how's the dress attire in the ambiance
right decoration smell as their scent
borders there is smell if I go in to
place to place smells like I walk out
immediately right service waiter how
long it wait to come like for instance
I'm here I come in I'm timing this if
I'm running a restaurant you got to do
this with your business I walk into a
restaurant okay a restaurant that's
empty and it took me six minutes to get
seated you're annoyed I want to know
from the moment I walk in to how soon I
get seated if you're on a lated
restaurant I'm coming for the service
and the food I have expectation of sit
down if I don't have a reservation
I'm okay with that but if I come in from
the moment you sit me down how long does
it take for the waiter to come and say
hello the other day I was at CPK in CPK
that we went to that one time you came
Mario came the day after we launched
their 2017 rewind if you remember that a
planer you came by
we wanted a thing see if you get with me
teak on Dylan five year old and a three
year old when he come with a kid I
expect you to pay attention the fact
that this father comes with a two boys a
father doesn't know you know it's like
I'm sitting there by myself it took
seven minutes for the girl to come say
hello to me so I finally I scream out I
say who's working in the side who's
working on the side and they all I go
server so far who's my waiter seven
minutes up in Connecticut to kiss you
guys don't pay attention to this the
place was twenty percent full so finally
the person comes very very good waiter
he comes I'm so sorry sir she's busy she
wasn't busy she had one other table but
he's willing to do that perfect I like
the teamwork there the other one needs
to be fired he takes an order he goes in
and the girl comes apologizes whatever
happens we leave I would have fired her
like this this is not her job to do
that's stuff I'm paying attention to
right speed quality of food without good
food you're a done deal right then you
have manager greetings how many times
you go to a restaurant I love when this
happens I'm sitting the way to keep scum
and doing their thing but a manager
comes how it has a service to you today
everything is good enjoying yourself is
there anything I can help you with not
at all thank you so much that little
subtle movement increases my impression
of the restaurant but at least 10% so if
you're not doing that I'd be doing that
right speed upselling do you upsell
would you like to try this on let me
take my favorite items on the menu is
this if you're going to have this it's
good to do this by the way you sure you
don't want to have a red wine with this
you know you guys goes good with this
red wine let me get what red wine I
recommend the other day I want to
capital choice I'll keep you guys for in
that capital choice Capital Grille a
restaurant here and my wife and I won
back-to-back it's not every day you go
to a restaurant twice especially that
kind of a restaurant but we went back to
back Friday and Saturday night look how
scripted this Capital Grille place was
we go in and the guy says oh my gosh hey
let me just tell you about this one you
know red wine that we have I think we
only have two or three bottles left when
he checked and this was the best bottle
of wine you want to have it's ninety
nine dollars that's that's a you only
have a couple bottles let's so what is
my
I say I want to try it great they bring
the bottle why not the next day I go
with Tom Ellsworth and his wife connects
it the same way and that's the same with
another way to come it's the same exact
bottle of wine and he said oh we have
this bottle of wine I think we only have
two or three bottles I got a check but
but if I do have it it's only 99 dollars
a bottle and I didn't say anything I
looked at my wife I said man that's a
script but you know what it's so
effective because how often do couple go
to st. Capital Grille restaurant back to
back they don't it works on the day one
they don't work on day two but there was
a script on how to up sub that up so got
them $99 upsell on the ticket 20% that's
a $20 more tip to the way too good for
him
that's up so what's this over here
specials can they say this special I
love when they say the specials and they
say it so eloquently you know what I'm
talking about like when they take
today's specials all with the special
base I don't know you know you know what
they're saying on it if we don't know
what they're saying but the way they
state in its temperature that this and
this is from Bulgaria and this is from
this it's like oh my gosh I want all of
it right there's a script to it there's
a way you present that these are
handling complaints technology this if
I'm running a restaurant I'm writing all
of these things down I'm very bringing
it down to five importance I'm scoring
my lowest area and bring my team
together of experts that know what we're
doing and I think how can we improve
this they call to action then attacking
all the call to action construction same
thing inbound outbound what's our script
do we know the client who is our client
are they a homeowner do we want $300,000
of homes the wheel and million dollar
home who's our ideal client
are we going after construction of
bigger condominiums who we looking for
right then prices over the phone for
instance if I'm running construction I'm
not giving prices over the phone the
first thing I want to do is I want to
come to your house I want to send
somebody to come to us to get an
estimate when I come to us and I see
what it is I'm paying attention to sign
if I see artworks not on the wall if I
see a rinky-dink you know a car parked
outside that's like a Toyota Corolla and
you want to do $50,000 job and that's
our minimum and I'm seeing the way the
house is not really decorated maybe I'm
paying attention to clues and then after
I find out when I visit the property I
get a commitment what kind of range are
you trying to get for this very kitchen
upgrade what we're looking some of our
budget is on $20,000 they want sixty
thousand for twenty thousand have you
gone already a commitment from there oh
yeah
we got an $18,000 commitment can they do
everything you ask for yes
interesting okay so then I have to
decide do I want even make a it is
and can I pry little bit more to know
who it is
how much work do they wanted to do but
they want better quality what quality
would all that stuff I'm asking for
right quote three options myself people
never leave with three options follow-up
clothes finishing at time delivering
then client testimonials and referrals
same thing if I'm running construction
I'm scoring these and I'm finding out
what I'm not good at then what I'm not
good at as I address it I bring a team
of three to five again I said what do we
need to do to improve this I fire the
weakest link that I have on the team
that's not doing their part right and we
put in like a plan of action to get them
we attack this improve the company I've
done this I think I've done this since
2003 2004 every time I find leaks in my
bin oh three was my credit score my
credit score was terrible for the system
to get uncool my credit score to a
twenty two savings investments health
relationship business improvement
leadership see your startup
entrepreneurship everything is a system
for you to put together once you do that
and you find the leak and you attack it
then you see three percent growth here
eight percent growth here nine percent
growth here thirteen percent growth here
and you don't even see the compounding
growth of it over a five ten year period
then all of a sudden years later people
are saying oh he got lucky or she got
lucky with her business no no no no
while you as the business owner went out
of business because you don't pay
attention to details this entrepreneur
decided to actually act like an
entrepreneur pay attention to the
details improve the business and now
they have an established business that
you claim they got lucky if you do the
same thing you will have the same
results but you don't pay attention to
the leak that's why your ship sinks I'm
not saying you won't see the person that
didn't make it so you're watching this
my challenge Q is to take out a sheet of
paper write out the systems and your
business identify exactly what the leaks
are get the opinions a couple other
people rank them find out what they're
suggesting to you put a plan of action
together try the bottom the weakest link
go attack the plan and see what happens
to you
that's my message of the week - if you
got any questions and comments thoughts
about this comment on the bottom pick -
everybody bye-bye
hey thanks for watching this video let
me make a case to you I believe you need
to subscribe to value tame and also join
the notification squad look there's two
ways you can learn about business wonder
way to go to college learn a bunch of
theories by professors who I probably
never run a business before or you can
watch value tainment
ran by entrepreneurs who have built and
sold businesses and you can learn from
our mistakes and what we did right and
by the way I'm willing to bet anybody
who goes and takes this boring route
verses watches value tainment I'm
putting my money this person who watches
value Tim is going to beat the person
who goes to college you don't believe me
test me on this this is why I'm so
certain you need to subscribe to value
tainment and learn the content so you
can also be successful I'm sorry